حلقه جديده من مسلسل الصواريخ الكوريه
الشماليه تثير رعب دول الجوار مجددا
صاروخان بالستيان اطلقتهما كوريا الشماليه
باتجاه ساحلها الشرقي حلقه لمسافه 500 كلم
لتعتبرهما اليابان تهديدا لامنها ولامن
المنطقه والمجتمع الدولي
تهدد سلامه وامن اليابان والمنطقه
والمجتمع الدولي ويجب عدم التسامح معها
انها تنتهي قرارات مجلس الامن وقدمت
اليابان احتجاجا جديدا ضد كوريا الشماليه
من خلال سفارتنا في بكين وادانه افعلهم
بشده
اطلاق الصاروخان جاء بعد ثلاثه ايام من
اختبار كوريا الشماليه لمحرك عالي القوه
يعمل بالوقود الصلب والذي يمكنها من تصنيع
سلاح استراتيجيا جديد يفسره المحللون انه
صاروخ بالستين
وهو النوع الذي يمكنها من الوصول الى البر
الرئيسي للولايات المتحده بحسب الخبراء
تصعيد طردي بين التدريبات العسكريه
المشتركه للولايات المتحده وكوريا
الجنوبيه وبين التجارب الصاروخيه والنوويه
التي تنفذها بيومكانك بما تعتبره الاخيره
تهديدا لامنها وتتناما ترسانتها من
الصواريخ البالستيه لتزداد كثافه
التدريبات المشتركه من جهه اخرى الا ان
الخبراء يفسرون هذه الدائره المغلقه من
التصعيد بانك تتذرع بالمناورات العسكريه
لتوسيع ارسالتها واستخدامها ورقه الضغط
على الولايات المتحده وحليفتيها كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان الى عمر العربيه